good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I
am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school of data
science and through grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of data
science methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's chosen theme is
data science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where each Friday we
will enjoy presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covet 19. these
include delayed Health checkups and treatments
mental health drug abuse increased obesity
and the long lingering health effects associated
with the SARS covid-19 virus participants selected
for our biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
Grant development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle Washington in
June of 2023. today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Christopher Murray who is the chair
of the health metric Sciences at the University
of Washington and the director of The Institute
for health metrics and evaluation he holds his
MD from Harvard he has a d Mill from Oxford and
he did his undergraduate work also at Harvard his
career has focused on the impro on improving
population Health worldwide through better
evidence he is a physician and health Economist
and work has led to the development of innovative
methods to strengthen Health measurement analyze
the performance of Health Systems understand the
drivers of health and to produce forecasts of
the future states of Health a in continuing with
our 2022-2023 biomedical data science seminar
series Chris's theme today is inter talk today
is entitled how well did the world do modeling
covid Dr Murray will describe how he and his
team search the body of covid-19 modeling globally
from the start of the pandemic and reviewed over 7
000 different models and articles and websites
of these a number of them had available data and
then they were able to evaluate the performance
of these models against what happened during the
pandemic using performance measures that
included forecasting skill they were able
to draw a number of different conclusions which
Chris is going to summarize for us and he's going
to make some recommendations on how we can do a
better job in the future and share some lessons
learned about how to validate models and Global
Health more broadly as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you are watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science Innovation
lab participants and alumni are Inc encouraged to
submit any questions they have by the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome Dr Murray we are super excited to
hear from you today thank you very much happy to
be here uh so I'm going to talk about our effort
to look at the sort of infectious disease modeling
Community response to covid uh we were part of
that community that responded and and participated
as one of the modeling groups uh the many modeling
groups out there and model covid really from March
2020 on our part right through till January of
this year so this is a perspective both of looking
at all the published and other models out there
and also one from having tried to do this um so as
you may or may not know there was quite a response
from the modeling Community to the pandemic
uh in this country and in many other countries
uh by uh we we I won't go into the sort of
systematic review part of this of trying to
find a republished study uh try to contact all the
groups that contributed to the cdc-led modeling
Ensemble Hub and the European Hub and all the
other efforts we also look tried to reach out
to different governments and ask them Which
models they used and in some cases obtained
modeling efforts that weren't published or in the
public domain we have found meeting our inclusion
criteria for models which was at least five
efforts so there's some a number of one-offs
that we found and didn't really spend time
evaluating but groups that made at least five
uh five releases of their model we included and we
end up with more than 300 that meet that criteria
now I'm gonna take a large diversion into uh how
we should or should not evaluate performance of
modeling because I think if I don't do that then
the conclusions on covid are are somewhat shaky
and uh interestingly uh the the Infectious Disease
modeling Community historically has not paid much
attention to their performance in forecasting uh
as opposed to other disciplines that I'm going to
draw on like weather climate and economics so uh
the diversion will begin with trying to go back on
the history of thinking about forecasting
both philosophically and quantitatively
look at various the sort of major
themes of forecasts evaluation
look at another case namely the imf's effort to
predict income and then dive into the results
of looking at all the covet models um and then
round out with General observations about how
we might do a better job as a spoiler alert I
think the key theme of this is the Infectious
Disease modeling community did a very bad job
but let me try to carry you along with that
so first uh forecasting has been around a long
time there's books on on forecasting there's a
nice book on the history of economic forecasting
going back to even the 1890s but there was really
quite a lot of technical discussion about
how does one evaluate forecasting uh in the
1930s even Keynes commented on this and there's a
paper by Tim Bergen in 1939 on more quantitative
thinking about evaluating forecasts so this
is uh not new terrain we have intellectually
an 80-year history of a forecast evaluation it's
that history just has not made it into much some
there's some exceptions into the Infectious
Disease modeling worlds perhaps the most
sophisticated in terms of the use of uh routine
evaluation of forecasts is the weather community
and I will come back to that over and over
just how we can learn a lot from the way the
scientific Community around weather forecasting
and even the World Meteorological organization's
efforts to encourage uh standardized
metrics for for evaluation of forecasts
I'm going to emphasize whether an
economic forecasting but many fields
Sports forecasting agriculture others use
forecasts and evaluate those forecasts and
with a little a few exceptions there's a
flu group that did has done some forecast
evaluation in the past and then a coveted
modeling Ensemble that used one particular
approach to forecast evaluation uh there's very
little of this in the Infectious Disease world
now I'm going to end up showing you skill metrics
because uh the modeling the forecast community
in whether climate economics and others have uh
tended towards since the 1980s measures that are
called skill which is for a given error metric how
you evaluate you know how good your forecast is
comparing it to a very simple Baseline model then
can give you a zero one scaled metric which is
very attractive because then you don't get caught
up in what does it mean at .032 of a root mean
squared error for one thing and a six in another
space they're not comparable numbers whereas skill
is really quite comparable because it's formulated
as one minus the error of your your favorite error
metric for your model divided by the error of us
of a particular Baseline model for for weather
that's super easy because the Baseline model
is the historic average of the weather tomorrow
uh from quantological data or economic forecasting
its historic growth rates and so you can go along
those lines and when we come to covet it'll be
an interesting question of what is the simple
Baseline model skills not only useful as a way of
thinking about measuring forecast performance but
it is also handy to address the question of
the skill Horizon when does skill go to zero
compared to a very simple Baseline model uh in
weather that's in about two weeks uh it's been
getting longer and longer as modeling has gotten
better uh and in economic forecasting it's it's
um you know a number of years into the future
and the big question that's still outstanding
on covid is what is the skill Horizon for
for infectious disease or for coping modeling
now there is a philosophical issue that comes up
a lot it came up in the literature around economic
forecasting right back in the 30s and 40s uh and
you hear it a lot around coven and that is if my
audience is the government and I model out what
I think is going to happen in the future and then
the government uses my model to because I provide
both a forecast and some alternative scenarios
and I persuade the government to change policy
let's say adopt mask use have a mask mandate
uh then I shouldn't be held accountable for uh
the successful use of my model to change policy
and it's very interesting I think the most
sophisticated treatment of this philosophical
issue is from the organization of economic
cooperation development oecd which is uh you
know basically the high income economies uh
that belong to the oecd and they do a lot of
income forecasting and I think Way Back 40
years ago they framed that if you are only
modeling for government and it's not publicly
available and nobody is taking an action based
on that then that argument might hold true that
maybe you should have a conditional assessment
of what happened conditional on in your model of
what was the policy regime the government adopted
but their argument was that in fact almost always
think the Federal Reserve on inflation or the
Federal Reserve on GDP growth uh or the IMF
on GDP growth uh these forecasts are not just
for government they get into the public space
and many private actors companies individuals
take action based on them and therefore while in
theory your forecast may change policy you as a
forecaster should be accountable if the public
knows about the forecast for also predicting
how individuals and and governments will re will
act and so that should be part and parcel of the
forecasting business and therefore we should be
able to and and want to report on forecast skill
and any metric you would like we'll probably come
back in Q a to this sort of philosophical question
now the economists uh are very focused
as are some other fields geophysics for
example uh on measures of accuracy
how well does your forecasts the
mean estimate of your forecast or the point
estimate compared to what actually happened
and many economic forecasts to this day do not
provide uncertainty they just say we think the
most likely growth rate for the U.S economy
in the next quarter is you know 1.2 percent
what and and uh there there is some growth
of probabilistic forecasting but not a lot
is still dominated by Point estimates because
that's actually what most decision makers act on
um and we'll again a big philosophical debate
about how important is uncertainty and we'll
come back to that here's a review of economic
forecasting that was published in 2022 by
budarak of just going through in a systematic
review of all the different error metrics used
in um the um economic forecasting world and
divided started into two large buckets metrics
that are in the units of whatever you care about
and just usually growth rates uh you know the
absolute error of various types in growth rates
and then metrics that refer to some version of
relative error whether it's percents or ratios or
even somewhat more complex measures as shown here
so same issue will come up with covet now another
area just to get to how messy this whole metric
space is is in here's a paper in 2021 of a huge
range of metrics uh in limon's paper uh used in
geophysics uh model performance assessment and
so that's you know there's a wide array um many
of them overlapping with what's in the economics
literature now there's a way to capture many but
not all of those measures uh in a general family
of error metrics where you take the absolute
value shown here as you know absolute value of
y minus y hat uh in the numerator and raise that
to a power Alpha that then encompasses people
who are interested in mean absolute error or
mean squared error Alpha being one or two and then
in the denominator you can capture this issue of
absolute error versus relative error by dividing
by y to avoid the situation where you divide by
zero you put a little number called Epsilon in
there just to avoid the problem the possibility of
dividing by zero and then you raise that absolute
value to Beta where beta is one your these are
measures of relative error beta is zero these are
measures of absolute error and anything in between
now the last little bit of this is Theta
which is uh the notion to make the results
um uh robust to outliers because these error
measures particularly when Alpha gets greater
than one doing a bad forecast in one week for one
location can make your overall error look terrible
and I will show this for covid uh and so the Theta
term here is to uh quote windsorize the the error
function so that if your error is above some value
Theta you uh don't keep making that contribution
to the overall error measure uh larger and
larger now it's easier to see this in a visual
so if you think about an arametric uh this
is true for you know you know in a likelihood
function but just in terms of these performance
metrics you can think of it uh visualize these
different approaches by showing the absolute
value of the error on the x-axis and the loss
that you're going to calculate on the y-axis and
you know mean squared error is the green line
as you a loss uh a error of two
gets a loss of four the square
uh and a linear one is the light green line where
an error of two gets a weight of two in the loss
function so you can see that in the difference
between the squared error and the linear of
course is that you are really saying I don't
want to make large errors in the case of covid
that large errors are much worse than a series of
smaller errors uh now the winds are rising says at
in this case at the value of two you are going
to hold the loss at a flat line and so you get
the gray line for a windsorized loss function and
if common measure the one that we use a lot and I
will show you is windsoride root mean squared
error where you windsorize the error at some
percentile of The observed absolute error we often
use 95 so once you're above the 95th percentile of
error you get the same you know bad weight it's
not getting worse and worse and worse and I'll
show you why this turns out to be important now
there's a group out there that uh I don't think
is relevant to covid that actually want to have a
concave loss function shown where an alpha is less
than one uh and there are certain applications
out there where that might be interesting
um but it is an unusual uh shape now in weather
in contrast to economic forecasting forecasts
are mostly probabilistic and so there's a
different set of metrics that have emerged
uh for predicting you know what's the probability
of rain tomorrow and these go back to the 1950s
there's again a huge array of these measures the
main ones are listed here reliability measures
uh coverage versus accuracy plot where you know
you count how in your 95 uncertain interval what
percent of the time the truth or the future shows
up in that interval uh and I'll give a little bit
more detail about Briar scores ranked probability
scores and then continuous rank probability scores
so using some concrete results here is the UK Met
Office plot of reliability and this is for their
um mid-term six month out forecasts uh
or actually you know two to four months
out forecasts of whether the temperature will be
higher than equal to or less than a climatological
averages so it's it's for weather this is long
range rough forecasting and on the x-axis they
show the probability of being in those three
buckets and on the y-axis they show The observed
probability so if you take all the forecasts
to 50 percent what was the the uh frequency
and reality of being above uh in the case of
the red line of being above normal temperature
and you want your model to be on the 45
degree line right and the fact that these
weather forecasts uh when the probability is
low the truth is higher and when the probability
is high the truth is lower points to the lack
of reliability of the forecast which is worse
for being in the middle and slightly better for
being predicting too hot or too low too too cold
another way of using the same forecasts again
using the UK Med office example is to use an
Roc curve these are receiver operating curves
I'm sure most of you are familiar with these
um for predicting a dichotomous outcome you have
the false positive rate and the true positive rate
uh at false positive on X true on Y and you want
to be up on the top left corner and then the ROC
you can integrate the area between the Curve uh
and a 45 degree line to get in a a summary measure
of that and again you can see this difference in
performance for predicting high and low versus
predicting in the middle interestingly the weather
communities is sophisticated enough that they
compute these metrics whatever they're looking
at whether it's weather or mid-range or climate
uh by location and they produce maps showing
you where models did worse or better so the
dark Reds are where they're doing well uh and the
blues are where they're doing poorly and out over
the oceans they seem to do rather well whereas
they do not as well uh in a number of land masses
other probability measures uh Brier in 1950 came
up with very simple idea of taking the predicted
probability of an outcome minus the observed which
is either zero or one of an outcome let's say rain
more than two millimeters and then just you know
squaring that and then adding that up across all
your predictions dividing it and you get um you
know uh the Briar score which is actually still
widely used there's a version of the prior score
where you have a a polygamous prediction you know
um think of in covid uh the analog would be
predicting covet incidence is low medium high
very high you can calculate your buyer
score for each of those categories and
then sum up over categories and over time
and you get a ranked probability score
and then the final version of this is uh the
continuous rank probability score where your
uh you have a continuous curve a prediction
the red line and then the actual observed
probability of the event is the blue line and
you compute the red area between your cumulative
probability distribution of the prediction
for y uh compared to what was observed for y
now the the there's a key distinction here which
is sensitivity to outliers which in the case of
code it's going to turn out to be super important
if you use a continuous probably uh rank score
you are very sensitive to Crazy outliers let's say
you made a really bad job one week and your model
went crazy and you predicted a massive epidemic
and it didn't occur in one place that can swamp
your overall CRPS whereas in the rank probability
score here if you set the Threshold at some level
you say you know I'm interested if I predicted
very high but I'm going to give the same weight
to the loss of predicting very high and and
absolutely insane it the RPS as the same thing as
windsorizing on the accuracy measures then builds
in some resistance to uh the extreme outliers
buddy that the weather Community routinely
like every week uh depend on for most models
is reporting their skill and they're not only
reporting skill but they're comparing their
skill to the main competitors they have and
in the weather world because weather models
are really quite complex um there's not that
many models that are modeling for the world
and you know most of them are listed here and
you get pretty routine uh uh assessments of skill
okay so that's some background history on
skill and the metrics and now we're going
to turn to two cases one very quickly on income
uh because I think in something's important is a
super complicated task because human behavior and
the policy response matters a lot for predicting
income and then uh we'll turn to covet and
the reason I want to show income is that I too
often hear from the Infectious Disease modeling
Community oh it's too hard that's why we do so
badly uh but in fact you know if you think about
the complexity of economies they are super complex
entities and with an enormous amount of individual
Behavior response as well as policy response
so I'm now comparing two measures of skill for IMF
forecasts over the last 25 years so ever twice a
year the uh the international monetary fund
predicts the next five years economic growth
for every country in the world and so there's a
nice time series of their forecasts they're all
publicly available you can go play with them
yourself and they have two they predict many
indicators that the one I'm focusing on here
is GDP growth rates and they predict them both
in what are called constant dollars on the left
which is after correcting for inflation and they
predict nominal dollars actual dollars that
you you go and spend which are called current
prices which you include economic growth
and inflation and what we're seeing here
is a comparison of just two skill measures the
skill measure on the x-axis is uh windsorized
um root mean square error and on
the y-axis is without the windsoring
so just to show that skill once
you wins your eyes for a number of
the predictions uh is better because you are
not uh taking the two or three countries they
do a terrible job on uh and really you know having
that drive the overall assessment to give you some
examples in other modeling that we do completely
unrelated covid uh we get not uncommonly an
example of where one modeling strategy in 99
of the cases gives you uh smaller you know
better accuracy but in one percent of the cases
worse and that one percent is large enough that
the summary measure of root mean squared error
is worse even though the model is better 99 of
the time whereas in the windsorized measure uh you
take away that and it sort of Accords more to your
intuition that if you're doing better in 99 of
the cases uh your summary measure will look better
here's another comparison again for skill skill
on the x-axis here is just what we were showing
windsorized root mean squared error and
on the y-axis is now a relative measure
and it's just to point out that there's very
little relationship between skill predicting
the absolute GDP growth rate versus the percent
error or the relative uh error in the growth
rate and that's often because when you have
a small growth rate like 0.1 percent and you
predict 0.3 percent well that's a 200 error and
that looks really bad at those measures so not
some people have uses for relative measures but
they're very unusual and have unusual properties
so fine last slide before we moved to covid uh
which is how good is the IMF at predicting well
for constant prices and and here I'm comparing
two Baseline models a baseline model that just
says GDP growth rate will stay will be zero into
the future which is a sort of not a great model
uh and then the four-year historical average uh
growth rate is what you predict into the future
and for uh current prices on the right
hand side that model the Baseline model of
a four-year growth rate then IMF forecasts have
you know skill of 0.4 in the first three months
dropping down to a skill that's around 0.15 on
a zero one scale and then interestingly sort
of increasing over time uh going up to a scale of
about 0.25 by five year five five years 60 months
if you have a really bad Baseline model uh namely
that the economies on average will not grow at
all which historically is not the case shown in
blue then you make the skill of their models look
better and this is a little bit of a game that
exists in these forecast skill World which is if
you pick a really bad Baseline model you can make
your skill look better so just a a warning there
on the left hand side skill is much worse once you
get past you know a one year down below 0.1 uh and
that's because it's in constant prices so now on
the left you have to predict both inflation and
GDP growth so the difference between the two means
that the IMF has been historically better higher
skill at predicting what's going to happen in
nominal dollars less good at dividing that future
growth into what's inflation versus not okay
let's go to code let's start with reliability
and I'm going to show these plots in some
cases for U.S models and for all other
locations combined for reliability I'm just
going to uh I'll do the same thing uh here so
for reliability these are all models about 80 of
them uh and combined and what is their reliability
so you take all the predictions of being above
a certain threshold this is for predictions at
the death rate from covid and you can see if the
threshold is how well do I predict the death rate
being uh over let's say three three per
hundred thousand uh which by the way is not a
um particularly low death rate but still then you
can see there's almost no information content in
the forecasts in aggregate because it's a flat
line and it should be on the 45 degree line so I
predict 50 being above three and what I observe
is in during the the pandemic was uh for those
forecasts that you know 95 you're above three
so lots and lots of forecasts that were too low
as well if you look at the Orange Line of 180
per hundred thousand uh when I predict or not
that when the modeling community on average
predicts eighty percent chance of being at a
high level huge level 180 per hundred thousand
The observed probability is about 60 percent
so over predicting really high surges
and this has been a characteristic of
some of the models throughout the pandemic
here's the same graph for non-us locations
and it looks a little better actually but in
general the slope instead of being 45 degrees
uh is actually quite flat and the flatter these
lines are the less information content there is
in the prediction so one if you were to compare
this to the reliability plot we saw for you know
three to six months forecasts of temperature
uh certainly not doing as well as as those
now we're going to go on to skill various types
and uh the question of course is the Baseline
model you saw how the choice of the Baseline makes
a difference for uh you know income uh forecasting
and so for covid what we picked is a baseline
And I think others have as well in like the
CDC Ensemble uh uh efforts at looking at skill is
covet staying constant from the last measurement
just hold it constant so it's a super simplistic
model so you would have hoped that we would the
the modeling Community would easily beat that now
skill uh the the relationship of skill will matter
if you do or do not take into account the outliers
and this is one way to visualize that I'm showing
windsorized skill at windsorizing at the 95th
percentile of the difference between Y and Y hat
in this case the code death rate versus just the
root mean squared error of of the death rate and
uh obviously the remain squared error is worse
and skill is worse when you use that because you
were affected by outliers but it has a huge
pretty large effect in in the case of skill
and here's another comparison this is CRPS
skill which is outlier sensitive and then
windsorized skills looking only at accuracy
remember CRPS is sort of a joint measure of
uncertainty and accuracy and important to note
that skill in those two two different metrics
um is really quite different so you
have positive skill for CRPS that can
have negative win through our skill
so just to note that and vice versa
okay so let's go start with basic uh here's
graphs for modeling efforts throughout the
pandemic so just everything that's been done
we're talking actually millions of forecasts
across the different groups by week and week out
lump them all together uh put forecast week into
the future on the x-axis and inside and outside
the US uh and basically on average the modeling
community has had negative skill so we're not
talking about you know a skilled 0.2.4.6.8
we're saying that we were worse than a flatline
forecast so this is a what I would describe as a
massive fail for the Infectious Disease modeling
community however if you go to windsorized skill
where you say okay we're not going to have the
overall judgment be driven by the crazy forecast
you made for one state in the U.S or one country
in in Africa or wherever that something just went
wildly wrong You released a forecast that was
you know impossible but and that throws off those
metrics Because by the way lots of modeling groups
did do that they just didn't have the quality
control to even stop on the releasing things
where something had clearly gone wildly wrong
so if you give people the benefit of the doubt
sense and windsori's skill then you get a less
depressing picture but still pretty poor namely
unlike weather and economic forecasting where you
get the classic curve or skill is greatest one
week out or one unit of time out you know one
year or one day one week uh and then declines
towards zero and you get to the skill Horizon
we see the opposite relationship in the U.S where
skill was worse than a flatline forecast out to
about three weeks then actually becomes positive
and uh goes up and stays positive and you see
this bump at 15 weeks and this is compositional
bias that namely the modeling groups that did
longer range forecasts on average had better
skill so as you go far more and more weeks out
on this graph you're getting to that subset of
modeling groups that that actually fared better
and that's why skill bumps up at 15 weeks same
story for outside the U.S you had negative scale
out to 14 weeks uh and then you get you
know a little bit of skill at the tail end
now what about the relationship between coverage
doing a good job on uncertainty for covet and
accuracy doing a good job on the point estimate
and this shows you for each modeling group
or across whatever they modeled throughout the
pandemic uh windsorized its skill on the x-axis
and coverage of the uncertain intervals on y you
want the coverage of your 95 uncertain renewable
to be 0.95 so you want to be at 0.95 on the y-axis
and you want to be as far out on the right hand
side as you can be on for skill and uh several
observations here first there's no relationship
between coverage and accuracy so it's not the
case uh in general that those that had more
accurate models uh had better on certain intervals
they're just sort of unrelated Dimensions here
um secondly there's a cluster of models up in
the top right that had for short range forecasts
one two three weeks uh you know good coverage
and skill of about 0.25 and those it turns out
tend to be models that are in those cases for one
location so there's a little cluster of modeling
groups that did forecasts for one location
and they did a good job in both dimensions
and then there's a call you know there's these
uh as you can tell by the colors some of the
groups that do long range forecasting
including ourselves down here on the
bottom right uh with you know moderate
um skill and but uncertain intervals
were were too small and we'll come back to
calibration at the end of this presentation
what about um the question of did we learn as a
community to do a better job during the pandemic
so here's skill during the course of the
pandemic so now the x-axis is calendar week
and there's no indication here that as a community
the Infectious Disease modeling Community
including you know extreme errors did a better
job over time so what about for windsorized skill
and in the U.S you can see that there
were periods where skill went up
for example in the period in this in the
sort of um you know April May June of 2021
before Delta hit most places and then when Delta
hit still dropped way down because people didn't
anticipate it the red line dips similar
story uh as we get into 2022 where there
was uh you know a drop in skill as Omicron came
on board models adjusted skill went back up and
then ba5 came along uh and subsequent waves
of Omicron and skill got dramatically worse
so overall both in the U.S and out no clear signal
that the community learned to do a better job
here's a a dynamic map of skill by location and
what's interesting here is to regardless of the
week out uh modeling all models participating and
I'll let it play again uh did a really poor job
for sub-Saharan Africa and a very poor job in East
and Southeast Asia with the exception of Malaysia
and then you get this phenomenon that skill goes
up towards the end and again that's compositional
bias where this the small set of groups that
do the longer range forecasting on average had
higher scale okay so rather depressing if you're
in in infectious disease modeling as as we are uh
so what conclusions can we draw from all this so
first off many modeling groups struggled with the
fundamental data they were fitting their models to
they did not have the resources or perhaps time or
inclination or skill set to do the Deep dive into
the data to make sense of it and they ended up
um you know reflecting in their models really
crazy data errors that were in the real time of
the pandemic being released and not being caught
and being dealt with um and that's true both for
the outcomes incidents you know reported cases
hospitalizations deaths but also for all the
variables that might go into a model uh such
as social distancing or mass use in the other
the other thing that many groups did on the
data front was because they didn't have the
time or the energy to go into the details of the
data uh they made you know extreme assumptions
that the infection detection rate remain constant
for example the Department of Defense had a whole
modeling effort throughout the first year of the
pandemic where they assumed that the infection
detection rate was 100 percent uh and of course
they knew it was not but they just didn't have
the strategy to to deal with that um so you know
at our end we developed an attempt to triangulate
using cases Hospital admissions deaths and the
zero prevalence data shown on the right in the
purple dots uh corrected for various biases
in it to try to in in real time compute each
week what some of these key parameters were like
the the infection detection rate the infection
hospitalization rate and the infection fatality
rate and how they were changing and that turned
out to be super important at least from our
view of sort of that data triangulation effort
uh and yet we had huge Divergence across modeling
groups on some of the basics like the IFR the ihr
or the IDR another basic Insight is that uh many
modeling groups stood up you know stepped up to
the challenge they said you know I'm an infectious
disease modeler or I'm a modeler in general I'm a
data scientist uh this is a national Global crisis
you know I'm going to throw my hat in the ring and
participate which was great to see people step
up and try to help uh but many of those models
were simple seir models uh you know in the in the
classic susceptible exposed infected recovered
I know ordinary differential equation box models
and they used simple fixed parameters like are not
um and uh then never change their model despite
all the learning during the pandemic and the
role of variants the role of vaccination the
role of antivirals the role of seasonality
the role of human behavior the role of mass
use and the like and so you know incredible
um you know uh focus on a
simplistic model and not changing
most models the vast vast majority over 95 percent
made no attempt to build into their models human
behavioral response you know social distancing and
mask use for example when things got bad nor did
they explicitly try to model how governments
would respond when things got out of control
and I can give you many anecdotes having
talked to many sort of political leaders
during the pandemic of modeling groups advising
them with these very strange you know um uh you
know assumptions that were leading to extreme
conclusions and extreme requests for resources
earlier in pandemic and when you ask modeling
groups why their response was oh you know we don't
know how or it's out of scope or we just don't
really know how to deal with behavior and policy
perhaps the most damning I think is the culture of
not reporting skill you know however you want to
measure Windsor High School whatever your favorite
measure of skill there is no culture in the
Infectious Disease modeling world of doing this
there's some bright exceptions the CDC modeling
Ensemble which was only for short run forecasts
four weeks but nevertheless they did periodically
try to look at skills so that's a bright spot
in this story but in general the Infectious
Disease modeling Community resists the routine
reporting of skill uh and in my view we will never
see better performance from infectious disease
modeling uh for forecasting purposes unless we
adopt what other fields do which is a culture
of routine real-time reporting around scale
bizarrely as a reflection of not looking at
skill modeling efforts that had negative skill
throughout the pandemic kept going so you had
groups that were notably worse than a flatline
forecast that just kept making forecasts
and um you know that that doesn't happen
in other fields if you think about sports
forecasting and what bookies do oddsmakers
do uh they will lose money if they did that
and so there's a self-correcting mechanism
in that community and in income forecasting
and weather forecasting there is a culture
of routine reporting so really bad modeling
efforts do tend to drop out pretty quickly
now a little side note uh we shouldn't be
too harsh on the folks that uh stepped up
and tried and did a bad job uh at least they
tried but there's a whole group of modeling and
some very very accomplished well-known infectious
disease modeling groups that never made forecasts
they were pundits on the sideline and they would
criticize forecasts but never made their own and I
think it's a pretty simple diagnostic there they
never made forecasts because they were worried
about having poor skill and didn't want to expose
themselves to that sort of um critique publicly
but it is curious that you know if not for covid
when would you ever step up and do uh forecasting
another thing that I think we have not learned
from the weather Community uh is that there's
a very simple post-hop fix used in the
weather Community to fix poor coverage of
um model predictions or to fix reliability
which is they routinely look at their model
performance in the last period of time and say if
I predicted rain 60 of the time and I only observe
rain 50 percent of the time then I post hoc take
my model prediction of 60 and call it 50 percent
and that post-hoc calibration improves performance
and it's a pretty simple device that we could
import into infectious disease modeling or
covet modeling or whatever else comes down
the pike uh so that we both get the uncertain
intervals to be accurate and also could shift
the mean of those predictions uh or the the
point estimate to get on the 45 degree line
there's you pay us you pay a price
for calibration which is you become
less capable uh but true of predicting you know
either end zero probability or 100 probability
but for covert modeling that's almost never
the case right nobody's ever been that great
you know we haven't seen skill up above
you know on average about a 0.25 or a 0.3
so my last slide here and then we'll have some q
a uh is what do we do in the future and we could
ask this question a lot and I think my view of
the strategy is sort of threefold one uh as in
the weather world uh we're probably all better
off if there are 10 modeling groups that are
um that have demonstrably good you know positive
skill that you try to build them up and have them
commit to routine and real-time reporting of
skills so they compete during the process of
an epidemic to get better and learn from each
other and if you never will as we saw during
covet if you don't do that but the idea that we'll
have hundreds of modeling groups with good skills
seems hard to do given all the work that needs to
go into keeping up with a disease as it involves
secondly a lot of the problems and models do Trace
back to lack of data or or the cost of acquiring
some of the critical data points and part of that
is governments themselves us being an example were
reluctant or very slow to release data and there's
many reasons behind that um you know some of the
analysts within CDC wanting to publish papers
before the other people see the data some worried
about the public misinterpretation of the data a
long list but bottom line is we're all safer and
better off if there is a commitment to release
the relevant data in a very short time period
and lastly I think and this is a little bit more
questionable because I don't have proof of it
but part of the problem of why modeling groups
did not adapt to the virus as a change you know
adding vaccination add in antivirals add in
Waiting immunity which is quite complex is
that those make models much more complex and
harder to converge and require a certain you
know both access to computation a certain set
of skills and it might be the case for those
of the models and for machine learning models
uh that having some uh standardized tools that
have those capabilities built in that are widely
shared open source and could then be changed and
adapted by different groups because you don't want
everybody to have the same model uh I think you
know that's certainly not what other communities
do to to do a better job they have large ensembles
of quite different models but you still need to
help groups get over the hurdle of the resist of
the challenge of incorporating some of these
more complex phenomena like waning immunity
so those are some Reflections on how we might do
better next time around uh given what I'll have
to confess is a rather depressing story of how
the modeling Community stepped up for the code
19 pandemic foreign thank you so much I'm filled
with questions um one of the things you showed
a slide early in your talk which was all the
different types of kind of cost functions that
people evaluated their metrics with respect to um
usually some sort of ratio of signal to noise in
however you want to Define that what question is
that people I presume make a choice of what they
want the denominator of their Baseline model error
to be or rather it's basically derived from their
model is that seemed a little bit it seems like
it would be difficult to compare across models
because they don't share a common denominator
and so that skill metric is sort of skill with
respect to that particular model but it still
you know doesn't have a common denominator is is
that is that perception correct no I don't think
so I think the the Baseline model which is you
know what you have to you have to have the error
for your Baseline model to uh calculate skill uh
you know if for example all the Kobe comparisons
it's the exact same Baseline it's that covet stays
flat okay so as long as the Baseline is the same
thing then then for a given skill metric rmsc mean
squared or whatever you want CRPS then that that's
the beauty of skill it is comparable okay uh is a
skill comparing uh weather skill zero one of you
know whether compared to climatological average
comparable to a covet model compared to a flatline
model uh yes no you know I think as long as you
pick the Baseline to be the the the best simple
Baseline for that field I think in some sense
you're still incomparable how much better are
you than a very naive model in the case of kobit
you might come along in the future as say uh you
know Flatline is a little extreme it's too simple
and so in fact we're we're skewing towards making
the models look good by picking a very simplistic
Baseline but already we look so bad that you
know I'm not sure that gets us off the hook
are there any um attempts to like look at me
more information theoretical metrics such as you
know KL Divergence or other things that try to uh
work directly on the the probabilities uh from an
information theoretical point of view there are
you know there's there's an information Theory
um justification if you will for the the CRPS
The Continuous rank probability score there
are some other measures like teals measure that
are you know are grounded in information Theory
um so there's a there are a number of uh error
metrics where people have tried to link to uh
information theory in some way are there any
evolutionary approaches to this where you sort
of mentioned you know skill which is I suppose
one metric of overall performance but if even
skill isn't working out very well is there
something like model Fitness that would allow
you to say okay in this generation of the model
run or whatever it is that that it did a good
job therefore it lives on those that don't do
well then fallouts and they are they basically
go extinct um is there any sort of movement
towards that that would help no and in fact
that's you know it's it's another way of framing
what I'm calling for which is you would hope if
there was as in weather routine prediction a
reporting of skill that bad models would drop
out right and we did not see that at all yeah
I mean you commented on that you know models
that were doing poorly just kept reporting poor
numbers and they did not just go by the wayside
you know from an evolutionary point of view
that the the ones with the best fitness should
have continued to the Next Generation and those
that didn't die off uh were still kind of around
no we we saw no shift uh and I guess that
graph of skill over calendar week is the most
you know depressing in a sense
that uh as an academic Community
um you know not to point fingers at any one group
but as a group as the totality of the Infectious
modeling community no self-realization
no Evolution towards better models
as we have a group of new newly minted faculty
members of Many Times building their research
networks and starting their careers uh working in
this space what sort of advice do you have as they
get started you know I I think it applies uh this
notion of skill applies not just to forecasting
but just to prediction in general um you know
uh you know some people call it forecasting or
now casting whatever you want to call it and
I just think it's very painful right for the
modeling groups to look at their performance uh
because it's very easy to if you don't look at the
metrics especially skill metrics uh it's very easy
to delude yourself for some reason that you know
things are going well and so I think it's the it's
the discipline of looking at some measure of skill
and saying wait because everyone well not everyone
we people in our Fields love complexity right uh
love to come up with whether machine learning or
Bayesian statistical uh models you know Revel in
complexity and it's it's a good discipline to
say hold on a second does the more complicated
approach actually give me better forecasts
and when you have numbers that are where the
scale is sort of incomparable and meaningless
it's very easy to miss the fact that you may
not have skill over something like a flatline
model which is a pretty low bar to get to so
just that that you know intellectual honesty with
yourself is super is a good discipline to adopt
do you think that there's a case for parsimony
here you mentioned like the level of complexity
um you know people always like to go for
the more what you know is maybe trendy or
apparently more sophisticated but
maybe sometimes simple is better
sometimes I think it's a very tricky walk a
road to walk because sometimes Simplicity is not
better because some phenomena are truly complex
but sometimes uh Simplicity is better and I I
like you know I I uh tell my junior faculty here
that are working on these sort of issues uh they
they do tend to fall into lumpers and Splitters
right there's a group of people who just see any
results or problem and think of the ways in which
more complexity will uh enhance the the assessment
and then we have the reverse phenomena people who
really like to go for Simplicity and it's sort of
getting that balance right and I think the only
way we can do that is with you know Guided by
some sort of metrics well Chris thank you so much
for sharing this work with us and lots of food for
thought about how we kind of evaluate these models
their their ability to successfully forecast
things and how we can measure that ability um
and I hope that we've learned something out of
this you know last couple of years where we were
really tested to kind of do this real time and
to find models that were effective and hopefully
we've learned a thing or two and it sounds like
you and your team are at the tip of that spear
so thank you so much for for sharing this with us
um I want to thank everybody who joined us here
on zoom and out on YouTube and uh wish everyone
a wonderful weekend and uh we'll see you later
bye everybody thank you cheers thank you Chris